we didn't have a lot of asians man we
had a uh
there was a rumor of an asian when i was
first
what was his name i'm not sure what was
the rumor what was the rumor
the rumor was
and i've talked about this before yeah
yeah i talked about this before uh
they had yeah they had a rumor that
there was an asian kid right and this is
after
because we got a latino kid
we got a latino not a family just one
kid
congratulations one guy one guy uh
nicholas was his name and he had a
little bit of light facial hair
everybody was fired up about that fire
there was a lot of rumors and stuff
going on around about that yeah um
because yeah people had never seen that
on children you know it's like
would be light hair on the face yeah
like this yeah people are like he's
trying to grow a side burn on his on his
chin
yeah so then i was on the wrestling team
in middle school
um right there
because panaskitas was 60 filipino
their wrestling team all the kids had
mustaches oh yeah all filipinos have
mustaches by the time they're 11. i mean
literally we're female and male is it
like a hand print like a fingerprint
we just grow mustaches like not but we
don't really grow the rest though what
we are like manny pacquiao mustaches we
all
even the female people yeah yeah yeah
mustaches but i remember like
wrestling against them with the first
time and they all have mustaches
right and we don't we're like we're kids
you're like bro yeah yeah but our team
was so good
yeah that we we beat them even me i
crush them yeah my brother we never ever
did um chris is that his name well steve
steve yeah he's close well there's only
three
there's jeans steve steve almost
killed steve almost killed the filipino
out there wow but my brother had no
facial hair and here's this old man with
a mustache that he's fighting against or
wrestling again
and my brother snapped him on the ground
we're like yeah old man
you know what man that's what you get
i'm only 14. i know but it was amazing
but anyway
so anyway so the face so the rumor of
the asian though
you heard a rumor yeah they had a rumor
that there was an asian boy in slidell
louisiana which was probably about 17
miles away
and so we had to get over there yeah you
know we were fired up and we
thought about it for a couple weeks and
then we started me until my buddies cut
grass man this kid
danny yeah who was a good friend of mine
and he had some
he had a couple of different
deficiencies but he's he's doing okay
now yeah
you know and he um we raised up some
money saved up some money
over about two months and then we caught
a taxi over there yeah
and we went to this place where they
were supposed to have
you know this asian boy chet i want to
say the name was chet i'm trying to
think off the text somebody chang
does that sound nice
yeah yeah it's a chat kid right does it
ever sound do you ever see him that
sounds possible
it doesn't sound it sounds it doesn't
sound plausible it does it does it
doesn't sound plausible because i've
never met an asian guy named chad yeah
there are in southeast asia there you go
it's either um i think it's either thai
or
oh well then chat mate bro chatman
the rumor so we got there and he wasn't
there it was a uh it wasn't there
it wasn't he wasn't there the name is
from the city
city of chester england
i know probably no yeah yeah and uh
yeah we went there and it was just like
a laundromat someone had opened up like
a new laundromat or like a cleaning like
a
right clothing but there was no was it
the asian run laundry mat
i don't know that could have been maybe
somehow something that got defused when
by the time i got tossed
you know i'm this is way pre-internet
yeah right
right this is back when what was the
first do you remember the first time you
ever saw an asian in the flesh
man i feel like it was a man
yeah i feel like it was a man with
glasses on yeah
but they didn't i could probably draw a
picture of him but i don't think that i
i could but i don't think that i could
tell you when how old were you
after that i mean i guess i kind of gave
up on it after the yeah yeah
yeah after the no show of chet yeah but
you would think that
you know go to you know saving up money
taking a cab to go see chat you don't
see them
that you would this you're going to be
keen to when you're going to see another
right so then when you see another asian
airport or whatever you would go oh my
god and that would be in your thing but
that's fine you're crafty dude huh
[ __ ] mate man would you say chickpeas i
wouldn't say [ __ ] i said checkmate
i heard i heard chickpeas set me up
did i just say this though dude yeah a
couple of things you did already okay
i would never put your strictly business
glasses on okay dude
so this is what i'm saying dude i just
washed my hair today i know you look
great but what i was saying though is
that you accused me of making tunnels
mm-hmm i didn't say that
you might have a checkmate i would never
say that dude clever pun very clever
on your podcast we talked about how you
can't tell us the difference
tell us apart asians that's not true i
know he's from laos
i know but if you saw him in this like
there was other five other laos guys
would you go oh that's that dude from
tiger belly or you'd be like no that's
five laos guys
like that's the guy from the cruise
first of all it's the same thing
everybody
does on the shirt yeah like bro if you
had a tag a name tag just said rico on
it you get [ __ ] all the time
so and look man i'm trying to work with
you guys
you know what i'm saying yeah
he's gotten tight with uh the jk guys i
know dude yeah
and a lot of them are vietnamese a lot
of them are from mexico there's not one
view there's not one vietnamese person
on that one
there's two mexicans there for sure
there's two mexicans yeah who knows what
there is i don't see colors bro
i don't see colored people damn [ __ ]
made again
did you say that
yeah you know what i'm saying are there
any racial slurs of pawn
i didn't say it or i would never say i
wouldn't say
i would not i would i know you would
never say that bad now that somebody
are there any slurs that white people
get offended by oh dude i'll tell you
what offends me if somebody says redneck
that offends me
oh why because i'm not a redneck and
people say it a lot of times and it
makes me mad you know but they probably
say it to you in a joking matter right
i mean i don't know you're pretty
sophisticated for a redneck but if you
say something to somebody you know in a
defense it just
i guess it matters how they take it so
if somebody does say it
and i'll be like you know i don't like i
don't like being called that you know
right but rednecks can't be as as bad as
the n-word or
or [ __ ] oh i'm not saying it's can i
say that she'll be
you're not calling me i'm not calling
you a [ __ ] yeah so no i mean
i i don't know man i think for different
you know here's the thing different
people affecting
people differently i mean here's another
thing like
i mean people like that were slaves you
know or that were
those people are all gone now you know
those people aren't with us anymore so
the effect that a word is going to have
it's not going to be the same on
somebody today
as it is going to be have been on
something that's true that's very true
that's true you know there's no way it
can be
uh yeah you know but yeah i don't know
what it's like to be called certain
things certain things don't affect me
you know what i'm saying you call me
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying like
you're not crippled though i'm not
crippled so i wouldn't that wouldn't it
wouldn't hurt my feelings very much yeah
you call me um you know uh
pervo or something or you know uh
yeah you know you do have a perfect vibe
about you yeah
do you really do i think you do i think
it's kind of cute but yeah yeah yeah
what but i'm almost there you think your
perfect vibe is cute
i think some of it is and we'll take one
more from uh email from paulo
oh paolo from brazil who was
who was the weirdest kid you remember
from your childhood and what did they do
that made them weird
the weirdest gift from my childhood oh
dude
i'll tell you who it was bro
um
let me think about who it was you tell
me who weird was i gotta tell you why
you know i um
when you said that question i thought to
myself i don't didn't know anybody
which made me the weird kid like i was
the one people thought
was weird i remember in in in middle
school
not even in elementary school i lived in
minnesota
and the kids used to throw not snowballs
at my head but ice rocks
oh wow and they just used as
hard as they can just throw it at my
[ __ ] hat why you collected them or
something
no i don't no one collects ice rocks
like okay we're being mean
he will be mean [ __ ] my bad man you had
an icicle collection at my home
you said you were the weird guy i could
see you collecting
and people were like hey here's another
one and he threw it on my head yeah
and it hits my head and i go thanks well
this one's shaped like rosie
no dude no they used to do it violently
i'm sorry man i would never do that to
you dude if you were my friend
i know you wouldn't i probably would
have put you in like one of those little
wagons you know
there's red wagons yeah i know the right
way yeah it's a chinese buddy on the
side of it
and i would have hooked you to my bike
dude yeah all around town oh that's nice
it's kind of cool so
like you you have a rickshaw for me yeah
yeah you're only a little bell
right yeah and then i just go ah chinese
yeah all right that'll be fun parade or
bow at people and stuff people throw you
beads through your chocolates
yeah yeah you eat them bro right like
i'm a deity of something oh yeah yeah
that's really nice and we go on a big
chocolate ride every day and you [ __ ]
just get all the [ __ ] chocolates and
sweets and people come out and wish you
well and give you baked goods
yeah yeah and if you like them that
means they're gonna have good luck and
if you don't like them then that means
it's not gonna go too well for them
yeah so it's all up to you yeah it's up
to me a chocolate rider
who's the kid that you're growing up who
did we have we had this dude named brian
uh
brian purvis the first wiga ever you
know and they don't have them anymore
they have a couple left i think outside
of maybe
cincinnati yeah but he was like
the first white kid that ever wanted to
be black and they'd never seen it before
and they put him in
mentally handicapped classes because
they thought he was mentally handicapped
[Music]
is that what they used to do with
wiggers uh yeah yeah yeah yeah well they
didn't know they'd never seen it before
yeah they put them in there wow so they
had people that were really you know
people that were just you know didn't
know what was going on
yeah deaf people blind people that were
you know freebase
victims all kind of stuff like that yeah
and then you just had brian's
uh purvis just dribbling an invisible
basketball
just wearing a [ __ ] charlotte hornets
pullover
starter pullover apex and just [ __ ]
you know
blowing menthols and [ __ ] yelling at
people yeah yeah yeah like oh man we
don't know what he has you know is
brian's still an institution or he's out
no he's not somebody sent me a picture
on the other day i think he's in prison
somewhere he's in jail or in or out of
jail but
yeah i wish him well he's a nice kid he
still looks the same had nice eyes i
remember that he had pretty eyes for a
young fella that
had a rare disease you know yeah yeah
but he was one of the wildest locally
you know yeah because people didn't know
what was going on oh we don't know you
know
science doesn't know yeah and he was
just you know nothing was wrong he was
just
you know he bought shaquille o'neal's
rap album and he just watched space jam
all the time
yeah yeah and he listened to boys to men
he would just wake that up
i had a friend named brady he was the
neighborhood kid
and with one hand he could pull a stop
sign out of the ground
oh wow gosh he had like a sub human
strength
right and then but he was also kind of
[ __ ] like
you would ask him a question he wouldn't
even know what you're saying oh yeah
yeah like how
how are you and you go and you just pull
it out of the ground right yeah see i
have leaky things in my body i could see
that
yeah you know when i was on the show i
would i did portland friday night
and the second show um what club at the
uh helium
how was it it's okay yeah fun and i was
on stage and then i
i i was doing a bit and all of a sudden
i just [ __ ] my pants oh yeah
have you ever shut your pants on stage
no i'm [ __ ] my pants like in a
couple of different places but i've
never seen my pants on stage but you
and i i had i stopped the show yeah oh i
went good night and i went back
backstage and then here's the crazy part
it was the first show friday night
because then i took my pants down and
there was a load of [ __ ] in my pants
no you don't have leaky [ __ ] oh my yeah
and then what happened was um
who cares what happened after that
i was like this is already disgusting
and it's already like here's the thing i
know i'm gonna just guy can i just
finish my story guy yeah you can all
right um
so i could i go to the manager i got the
manager like they manage your [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude no i go grow
can you go get go to the store and get
me a modium id
what right because we had a second show
from what the periodic table no i'm
audio
no that's not an element bro yeah it is
no i know it's looking down
a motivated emoji where does honey come
from huh yeah
yeah honey from trees come from the
woods
yeah yeah but uh he um wouldn't do it
yeah oh give me a motion because he's a
[ __ ] adult dude no no
how am i gonna do the second show if i
have diarrhea i don't care wrap your
body in something dude and get out there
[ __ ] boy
you know peddle the [ __ ] riddle [ __ ]
boy underwear
all that stuff man oh wow yeah it was a
disaster friday night
you never [ __ ] your pants man let me
think about what happened to me one time
oh i remember one time i got stuck in a
tunnel my car broke down in a tunnel in
uh pittsburgh
and i had to defecate extremely and
that's french actually for [ __ ] yeah
yeah
and i had to defecate and uh so i got in
my back seat in my car and the only like
i didn't have any choice this was like
you know it was like something gotten
into my body like a pink eye had gotten
into my stomach
and uh and all the [ __ ] in my body was
coming out of my body
yeah it was that in your stomach yeah it
was like hey we need all this [ __ ] out
of here i gingivitis once in my stomach
yeah
and i got diarrhea from that too yeah
really yeah yeah i know how it got down
there and i had to defecate into a
frisbee out of upside down frisbee was
all i had
be real yeah yeah and so i'm in this
tunnel there are cars
whizzing by here's the crazy thing yeah
extremely hard to
poop when cars are going by 50 60 70
miles an hour and
furious too yeah furious like and also
white people like it was pittsburgh so
it's furious white people driving by
i can if other people are some certain
ethnicities i can [ __ ] easier when
they're driving by
honestly you know like if a couple of
brothers are rolling by blasting some
[ __ ]
good music i can [ __ ] blow ass all
day into a frisbee
no problem part of you know everything
is everybody's you know everybody seems
like it's more laid back yeah yeah
but angry white dudes you know rolling
by you know
six seven well they would probably call
somebody too huh oh they weren't calling
anybody i mean the only
free finger they had they were waving it
out the window
yeah they weren't using it to dial the
phone so you shoot on a frisbee out of
[ __ ] in the open
now the yeah not the top part but the
bottom part a frisbee is basically a cup
basically the size of a plate it's a
plate a plate
well a plate is just a cup that's way
easier
hang on are you a plate is just a wide
wide white coat
or you pulled over well i pulled it yeah
i pulled over the car i think honestly
i'd run out again just [ __ ] on the
ground why did you have to be like
yeah so it's dark [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in a
tunnel you play [ __ ] okay you should be
familiar with tunnels dude
why huh because of vietnam because
you're gonna do that [ __ ] again right
now man what [ __ ] bro why
why are you
i was digging tunnels in the ho chi minh
trail and trying to attack you people
no i thought you mean that was the fruit
juice the pomegranate fruit juice that's
always in there
bro i don't believe in vietnam i don't
believe it and it happened
are you those uh they never found the
boats dude oh
right it's just like slavery they never
found the boats
what do you mean tunnels though bro so
anyway i'm in a tunnel i'm in a tunnel
and there's only two lanes going each
way there's no there's nowhere to get
out in a tunnel
like in a tunnel you know cars are
whizzing by yeah and so i had to get in
the back seat and defecate into this
frisbee right
and um and then wait for the cops to
come
why did you call them how they call the
cops
somebody i i well somebody not somebody
i had just [ __ ] in a frisbee in my car
and i needed help yeah
there's a lot of things i didn't learn
from that story
i'll tell you what i didn't learn okay
say something i didn't learn
that a fris a cup a cup and a plate of
the same [ __ ] thing they're not the
same thing
depends on you depends on who where you
are how strong the gravity is in an area
how fresh the cup
how recently you made it how how warm is
the clay
a [ __ ] cup is this a plate is just a
wide wide cup the sides can't get along
a poem that's all it is that's the truth
dude
wow go beat a plate apart with a hammer
and then tape it together
yeah and don't do a good job would a
bowl be the same as a as
a as a plate go beat a cup apart i'm
sorry with the hammer
that's true you flatten it out maybe
they're they're taped together
right what do you have you have a
[ __ ] plate you gotta play
and you [ __ ] won how does he take
that [ __ ] strictly out of your eyes
dude i got these in another country you
idiot canada can i can i try them on
yeah sure yeah yeah are they
are they special did they do stuff huh
are they those no i did [ __ ] up last
week
let me see how are you doing last week i
actually went in there there's a lot of
i wore those 3d glasses to the beach
actually and they [ __ ]
almost burned holes in my eyes dude i
had them on in the sun for like about
two hours you were 3d glasses out in the
sun it's
not good for you that's what bobby does
he he um watches for six hours at a time
videos of people with uh with who are
color blind
and they put on that those special
glasses their family oh that's cool
yeah they're calling chroma tears yeah
have you ever heard of those seen those
videos
they're the best you'll cry i'll cry
really yeah like
you'll see an old man and you put
glasses on they'll give him a pack like
happy birthday
uh you know grandpa phillips
what's this and they'll go it's why does
he sound like a slave owner yeah
what's this and they go well it's um we
all chipped in
because they're expensive yeah yeah to
get you these whoa the glasses
right and they'll be like yeah they're
glasses he's like
i gotta try them on right now yeah
they're like yeah
drama right now so he'll he takes them
for like 20 minutes to open it yeah
and they all they'll always read the pet
like there's like always a little bit
right
uv ray yeah right and then they put it
on
and then this is what generally happened
they'll take it off and they'll go oh my
goodness
and they just start crying and they
start crying for a second and they'll
put it back on
oh my god because what happened and what
is it
strippers no mess
titties no they've never seen green who
gives a [ __ ]
they're 80 years old bro it doesn't
matter imagine dude
imagine your whole life right yeah you
thought that you know
the sky was just gray and then you turn
up put on no yeah imagine putting your
and then they're blue you see colors
where then they'll go oh wow
they'll go no no no no no put out the
glasses on the glasses you only see
black and white right now yeah yeah you
see black and white right now
right well you you'd be his like wife
and like give it right and here you go
here you go um grandpa phillips
your eye yeah and then they'll do that
yeah and they'll start crying
okay
okay i don't know what you're doing
right now i think he's acting yeah
falling asleep
yeah yeah dude and it happens to a lot
of senior citizens
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa dude yeah
that's the appropriate way to address
somebody with a mental illness
okay just say this you [ __ ] idiot you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
bro don't make me take half to see alice
right now all right i'll just say this
right now okay
yeah colorblind you're born with it yeah
are you
their whole life maybe it's maybelline
so their whole you [ __ ] [ __ ]
listen to me right now george laughs
dude all right he's from another country
he's from idaho
right so they can't see that he was he
could have lied colorblind
they have it their whole lives who just
people that are colorblind not anyone
specific
yeah i think if people are colorblind i
think we got
we got to get them more colors yeah yeah
yeah that's what enchroma does and
here's another of the
series of videos i cry at yeah is the
hearing one oh
oh right yeah wait what they
they can't hear your fart for the first
time that's what have you heard that
they have one some guy never heard of
fart and then he puts on like a special
hearing aid
farts yeah
he's like he's shaking the guy's butt
trying to get him to do it again
and the queef is even [ __ ] oh man my
nephew's deaf
and he has a cochlear implant and when
he's sick of everybody he just turns
everything off wow
that's an option that he has he's like i
can't i won't listen to my mom or dad
just turns it off and i think that's
going to be the future i think you're
going to see a lot we're going to start
to control our senses a lot more than um
then you know like we've looked at them
as blessings in a lot of ways and i
think we're going to start to
control them i think it's one thing
you're going to see people turning down
their ears
people being able to shut their eyes off
if they just want to like stop the
intake serious
yeah i feel like that would be really um
useful for somebody like me because i
feel like a lot of
stimulus overwhelms me a lot so if i'm
seeing too many things or there's too
many things happening
well just close your eyes i get freaked
out like it causes me anxiety
yeah i have to like receive things one
at a time
i can't drown noise out here at all why
can't you just put earplugs in
well she could bobby but we're also
talking about technological advancements
if you want to be a caveman dude you
know yeah but if you don't want to see
close your eyes put ear plugs in and
then do that thing
or somebody who's autistic somebody
who's who instead of seeing like
for instance somebody without autism
they look at your face
and they just see a face somebody with
autism they look at your face and
they're looking at a million different
photographs like that's how they
perceive things it's in it's an
overwhelming
amount of stimulus that they receive it
that they receive
um so yeah like if i'm able to turn that
off or mute it
it might help a hundred percent so when
they they see people they see like a
dream board or something
like a bunch of stuff yeah like when i
look at your face it's just a face right
but for them it's like
so many different bits of information
coming all at once yeah
it's more than just a fake it's a fiasco
it's like everybody
yeah it's like watching like a it's like
watching a marathon or something it's
just a lot going on
yeah and i wish i had all you could turn
up your autism like a you know get a
crank on your back or some type of a
nozzle you could turn it up to like
you know become more artistic hyper
aware whoa
be really interesting you can go to
vegas and make a lot of money
yeah you don't want to be some [ __ ]
kook that uses it like that use it for
something positive if you don't be one
of those weirdos in there just
cranked up on auctions yeah
no yeah man you're better than that no i
did that
you're taking a bus up there with 700 of
your buddies just to [ __ ] make
1200 and come back all smoked that on
cigarettes
dude maybe a 300 [ __ ] massage you're
better than that
you took way too long man we're at the
end of the podcast now
everyone also everyone else called in
country
bill burke called on time everyone
called on time
i know it's you it's stevie
[Laughter]
stevie weavey what's up
oh hey steve how's it going that's kind
of like the other phone call
yeah in san diego
i know i remember i remember because
you're my brother we grew up there
yeah yeah that's me um well
look so um i've been trying to get you
as a guest on the studio leadership
thanks for calling it i love you so much
you know that brother
i love you too man and uh you're one of
the sweetest guys you're gonna want a
nice thing for you man and i'll never
forget it
but not that we're gonna continue to do
stuff together
i know that i mean i know you only wait
two hours a day
you're the best too okay theo good night
good night i mean come on that's it
smile bobby smile for the camera
you know what i'm really impressed by
how well this actually went that was
great you were great no i'm i thought
for sure that nine out of ten phone
calls would fail
but it didn't only theos did yeah
he was probably just doing uh